[Musica]
buonasera un grande piacere essere qui e
poter parlare tra l'altro dopo sebastian
non ho sentito il suo quello che vi ha
raccontato ma ho avuto la possibilità di
incontrarlo quest'estate stanford è uno
dei nostri dottorandi peraltro sta
lavorando in remoto assieme a lui quindi
mi fa molto piacere questa introduzione
di oggi continuerò questo discorso e vi
vorrei parlare di collaborativo visual
intelligence vi vorrei parlare
ovviamente della parte artificiale
dell'intelligenza quella che per noi che
siamo ingegneri informatici è una
normale materia di studio ma che ormai
sta diventando pervasiva e di uso
davvero dappertutto sui media nella
società e nell'industria e tra tutta la
intelligenza e vi vorrei parlare della
intelligenza visuale cioè della parte
divisione che spesso come tipo di
intelligenza e abbastanza bistrattata
nessuno di noi dice che una persona
intelligente perché vede bene ma in
realtà dovete pensare tutti sappiamo che
nella nostra corteccia al 30 per cento
dei neuroni e utilizzato per la visione
solo l'otto per cento per il tatto il 2
per cento per l'audio per cui per noi la
visione un aspetto estremamente
importante della nostra intelligenza che
ci permette di ragionare ma l'evoluzione
naturale ha portato a diverse forme di
intelligenza il mio gatto in realtà è
molto più intelligente di noi per quel
che riguarda la parte visuale a molte
più sinapsi collegate e che 15 perché
gli permettono di lavorare in modo più
reattivo nella visione di quanto
facciamo bene perché vi ho raccontato
questo perché adesso l'intelligenza
artificiale è di fatto un altra forma di
intelligenza che si sta evolvendo in un
modo estremamente più veloce di quanto
non abbia fatto l'intelligenza naturale
da quando sebastian e nel 2011 ha
presentato questo ed adesso le cose sono
cambiate moltissimo e soltanto l'anno
scorso di mind ha realizzato una rete
rete che allo stesso numero di sinapsi
che al nostro cervello e quindi è chiaro
che quello che si sta facendo e che si
potrà fare nel prossimo futuro e
l'intelligenza artificiale è chiaramente
molto alto pensate che di tutta la parte
dell'intelligenza artificiale c'è una
disciplina che si chiama computer vision
visione artificiale che ho il piacere di
studiare che il segno da vent'anni a
modena che ha proprio la school
lo scopo di riprodurre la intelligenza
visuale sul calcolatore quello che
possiamo fare adesso è veramente
incredibile anche incredibile per me che
c'e lavoro tanti anni non so se è
riuscito a vedere quel quell'immagine
che che è di sopra sulle slide questo
lavoro che un dottorando dell'università
di modena in questo momento sta facendo
in facebook assieme a noi per non solo
riconoscere il contenuto dell'immagine
ma anche poterlo descrivere a parole il
linguaggio naturale quindi non solo di
riconoscere che c'è una persona delle
cose ma anche che c'è una persona che
sta guardando dentro un frigorifero
ecco questo tipo di applicazione questo
tipo di attività che stiamo facendo in
visione artificiale ha una storia molto
antica è da circa 40 anni che ci sono
dei risultati molto interessanti
qua vi mostro qualcosa che per noi ormai
è preistoria
nel 2003 abbiamo lavorato con san diego
per riconoscimento di auto sulle
autostrade
sempre nel 2003 abbiamo lavorato con
ferrari per anzi con persone che sono
qui e oggi che saluto per riconoscere
confrontare le traiettorie dell'auto
utilizzando la geometria utilizzando la
statistica
quello che vedete qui che si vede molto
male sono gli esprime esperimenti nel
2003 per riconoscimento delle persone e
questo è un lavoro fatto da annuncia che
è poi diventato il sì o di moby l'hai
venduto per 15 miliardi e passa di
dollari a dentale
nel marzo di quest'anno quindi queste
diciamo studi quest'attività di dieci
anni fa adesso sono diventati prodotti e
la industria della computer vision in
questo momento è una delle industrie
nell'ambito dell'informatica
probabilmente più attiva
i dati che ci sono adesso ci dicono che
è dal 2015 al 2022
ci si aspetta un aumento del 33 per
cento ogni anno di fatturato
nell'industria informatica che riguarda
la computer vision passando a circa 5
miliardi al 2015 e 50 miliardi di
dollari appunto nel 2022
e questo significa che non è soltanto
ricerca quello che stiamo facendo ma in
realtà io vi voglio raccontare però di
visione artificiale non soltanto come
discorso generale ma nella sua misura
collaborativa e il primo tipo di
collaborazione che vi voglio raccontare
una collaborazione tra esseri umani
perché il fatto che in questo momento
attraverso il di planning attraverso la
pattern recognition abbiamo ottenuto dei
risultati così interessanti deriva da
una grandissima collaborazione tra
ricercatori e scienziati di tutto il
mondo e tra grandi aziende anche
illuminate che ci danno la disponibilità
di lavorare su dati su macchine e tutto
in open source per poter lavorare
assieme
e i risultati che si ottengono sono
fantastici 2016 nvidia fornisce open
source software per riconoscimento della
strada in telco le reti di colture ci
permetterà di ottenere dei risultati
come questo quello che vedete qua sotto
è un risultato per l'analisi in tempo
reale del movimento che c'è attorno a un
auto che stiamo facendo con panasonic e
tra l'altro da un annuncio qui e che è
in tempo reale perché è un'informazione
che mi è arrivata stamattina che
panasonic donerà l'università di modena
e reggio emilia
un altro server come quello che ci ha
donato facebook lo scorso anno quindi è
veramente una cosa nuova di cui
onestamente siamo molto felici bene
tutta questa collaborazione tra
ricercatori
tra anche grandi aziende deriva dal
lavoro fatto in tante parti del mondo ma
sicuramente soprattutto ha fatto da
persone con mei alcune come sei lì che
mi piace ricordare alcune il direttore
di facebook e iaia new york ed è stato
il primo che ha realizzato la rete
profonde di tipo neurale per
riconoscimento del di zip dei pos
transcode negli stati uniti e assieme a
lui voglio ricordare fei fei fra i
fedeli e professore a stanford e a
google ed è stata la prima che nel 2009
ha pensato a questa grandissima
collaborazione tra persone e macchine in
che modo inventandosi l'idea di creare
il più grande dataset open source
disponibile di immagini annotata da
esseri umani in questo momento sono
circa 14 milioni di immagini che sono
stati annotati a mano da persone
ovviamente pagate per questo indicando
più di 22.000 concetti cosa servono
queste questi dati queste immagini in
cui c'è scritto questo è un frigorifero
questo un'auto questa è una persona sono
stati dati a disposizione della comunità
internazionale per poter lavorare e
creare sempre di più delle reti capace
di lavorare
assieme ecco e che cosa possiamo fare
con questo lo so se è riuscito a vederla
perché l'immagine molto scura però uno
degli esempi che possono essere
realizzati questa è una cosa che stiamo
facendo assieme ad euro e combo che è un
laboratorio francese che è un discorso
diciamo ancora molto di ricerca per
poter riconoscere le emozioni alcuni
psicologi hanno annotato amano più di
18.000 video presi da diciamo da la
situazione molto diversi come queste è
quello che stanno imparando le reti
piano piano lo presenteremo fra un mese
in inghilterra è la possibilità di
riconoscere le emozioni delle persone
che sono all'interno di un video
ovviamente se questo possiamo fare con
dei video con hugh grant poi
probabilmente potremmo farlo anche con
una persona che sta in auto o con tutte
con vinciamo in moltissime altre
situazioni bene vado avanti per dire che
questo tipo di risultati come vi dicevo
si ottengono soltanto con una
grandissima collaborazione persone e
macchine in questo caso questo è un
altro esempio di qualcosa che stiamo
facendo come azienda
milanese che ci ha fornito 150 gran
premi annotati a mano per poter
riconoscere creare delle reti capaci di
riconoscere i sorpassi o di riconoscere
degli altri eventi importanti in un
video di questo tipo di nuovo se non ci
fossero stati gli esseri umani che amano
attraverso dei file come vedete di sopra
possono indicare alla rete dove sono i
sorpassi e dove non sono queste reti non
sarebbero stati certamente in grado di
imparare questo che vi faccio vedere un
esempio che mostro sempre perché mi
piace tanto e qualcosa ancora di più
perché noi stiamo insegnando alle
macchine ai computer cioè di fare le
stesse cose che fanno gli esseri umani
attraverso altre altri computer
quello che vedete qui sono delle reti e
artificiali che stiamo sviluppando
all'università di modena e reggio emilia
che simulano l'attenzione umano alla
guida quindi lasciamo stare la guida
autonoma supponiamo che le macchine
possano guidare in modo automatico e
tanto lo stanno già facendo
effettivamente quello che vorremmo
aggiungere fra un po è uno stile di
guida simile a quello di un essere umano
per fare questo chiaramente la faccio
breve abbiamo utilizzato degli altri
computer che hanno imparato dagli esseri
umani quindi gli esseri umani che non
hanno scritto io sto guardando destro
sta curando sinistra ma utilizzando
telecamere nei tracker telecamere
sull'auto abbiamo unito assieme questo
in programmi che hanno aiutato altri
programmi a potere lavorare
quello che stiamo facendo qui
naturalmente non si fa solo qui ma si fa
non si fa soltanto per le auto ma si
fanno anche per le persone
queste ad esempio di qualcosa che stiamo
facendo con la duke university per
riconoscimento di persone in ambienti
aperti in ambienti cittadini ma nel
prossimo futuro si potrà fare in
tantissimi altri campi e con questo io
concludo concludo per dirvi che io sono
certa che nei prossimi cinque anni la
visione artificiale sarà più potente
della nostra visione su questa ne posso
essere decisamente certo non soltanto
perché i calcolatori sono più potenti
del nostro cervello un punto di vista
computazionale ma anche perché i punti
di vista che un calcolatore può avere
sono molto
fiore dei nostri un calcolatore una rete
di calcolatori potrà integrare viste da
un drone visto e da una macchina vista
telecamere di sorveglianza o da robot
oppure visto dal immensamente piccolo di
una di una laparoscopia all'interno del
nostro corpo oppure da tantissimi altri
sensori e quindi l'unione di questi dati
sicuramente darà una potenza di calcolo
la visione maggiore di quello che noi
possiamo fare ma io su questo sono molto
ottimista perché questo potrà essere
fatta da una parte in collaborazione con
gli esseri umani e dall'altra per gli
esseri umani per aumentare le nostre
capacità per ottenere una nuova
rivoluzione che non è è sicuramente
nell'ambito dell'industria le
nell'ambito dell'industria automotive
nell'ambito dell'industria della
robotica
ma è anche nella scienza e anche
nell'ambito della cultura e am che ne
andò b dove la medicina e quindi io
credo che il prossimo futuro per noi
sarà sicuramente roseo perché avremo
delle capacità in più come abbiamo avuto
grazie all'informatica negli ultimi
dieci anni
vi ringrazio
[Applauso]
[Musica]